There was a examination,
the young people,
if you want to go university,
you have to taste,
take the examinations,
so I failed it three times,
but I feel for funny things that I
filled a key primary school test for two
times and I've filled three times for
the middle school,
Middle School for three years I tried to
fill into universities,
so apply jobs 30 times.
Got rejected.
I went for a police.
If you're not good,
I went to either even the KFC.
When KFC come to China Cup,
did I say 24 people?
Went for the job.
20 three people accepted.
I was the only guy and we went to four
please.
Five people.
Four of them accepted.
I was the only guy that I receive,
so to me being turned down,
rejected.
Oh,
by the way,
I told you that I will apply for Harvard
for 10 times a day.
I know.
I think we have to get used to it.
Even today.
I don't think this world,
they're not a project.
If we know the only thing we have a gift
shop,
the only thing need to change ourselves.
We don't complete.
Whether you were successful,
not successful.
I find that people,
when they finished the job,
if the always complete the others,
this guy would never come back.
If the guy only checking himself,
yeah,
something wrong with me here.
Something want me to get there.
This guy has.